I'm Patrick made of your host of ie10
weekly and earlier today I was on a
flight back from Ohio and I was thinking
about we were having a cup of
conversations with friends and I was
thinking about you know when we were
kids 10 11 12 13 years old you know kids
would say what do you want to be when
you grow up and people would say I want
to play baseball I want to do this I
want to do that but you would hear
people sound will be a multi-millionaire
I want to be rich I want to buy this for
my mom I want to buy that for my dad I'm
going to take them everywhere I'm going
to buy a nice car for my dad I want to
have a nice house I'm gonna you know we
talked about being millionaires right
and then we become older and we start
thinking oh my goodness it's so hard
these people became millionaires they
have rich families they have all these
fantasy degrees they're smarter than me
they're better than me they're this this
this is that and then we play small and
we stay in this box and our life becomes
a regular life and we don't ever really
find that if we're capable of having
that life of being a millionaire
ourselves and the reason why I'm using
the phrase millionaires because you know
many times people think for someone to
become a millionaire you need to come
from a rich family or you need to be
extremely smarter than everybody else
etc etc etc and I asked my team I so
once you pull up some numbers to find
out what percentage of Americans are
self-made millionaires and self-made
billionaires fidelity did a study
according to fidelity eighty six percent
of millionaires are self-made eighty six
percent of them are self meaning only
fourteen percent had family helped him
out financially they came from rich
families eighty six percent of my
regular people and billionaires 68
percent of billionaires according to
Forbes are self-made billionaires I put
the links on the bottom if you want to
see both of them on the bottom of
description and just last week I had
lunch with a president of USC and I was
invited by my good friend David and from
csq magazine it was 14 of us sitting
there at counting gallon on USC campus
and it was a lot of successful business
people that were there and we had a
chance to hear from the president for an
hour and hear a lot of great wisdom to
share with the rest of us and you're
sitting there with other people who are
very successful and you sit there and
ask them questions now you know this
person is
worth a lot of money they made a lot of
money what made this person become a
multimillionaire Decca million or a
billion or whatever this story is it's
rarely ever somebody saying I always
wanted to be a millionaire never it's
never that case never ever the case you
ask them to question and it comes back
to pretty much deep down inside they all
look different personality is different
some of them are very loud eccentric
pink shirts pink ties colorful socks big
personality some of them are very quiet
some of them are married some are single
some are white some are black some are
Hispanics of our Asian some have degrees
some don't have degrees all of that
stuff is irrelevant but there's three
things are very relevant
now you'll see amongst every single one
of them one high level of desire to they
take action three they're clear on their
purpose this formula was written a book
called Laws of Success by far my
favorite business book I've ever by
Napoleon Hill these are action purpose
let me explain to you what it means so
maybe you can connect with this go back
to high school
think about the prettiest girl in high
school everybody 108 all the guys wanted
a date and think about the desire for
all the guys who wanted a date or maybe
go to prom with or was what very high
right but action very few guys were
willing to do what take action and go
ask her out because she may say what no
and you may get rejected on all your
friends may laugh at you so because of
humiliation and embarrassment you didn't
take that action so your desire sigh but
you never really found out she says yes
many cases when you meet a friend and
you say I always wanted to ask you she
says I would have said yes right desire
action then its purpose some guys asked
to grow about their relationship only
lasted three six twelve months but some
guys desire to be what there was hi they
took action but their purpose was to see
if that's a wife to build a family with
that purpose is higher see to become
very successful and have a shot at being
a self-made person your purposes needs
to be clear as well a lot of people have
a lot of desire they don't have a prom
working or there's a lot of hard-working
people I know but they really don't know
what they want means like they're just
running around you know if I make money
I want to buy this buy another no
there's got to be a clearer purpose when
you put those three together you could
have whatever you want in your life
you gotta know your desire your action
and your purpose my message choose when
you don't watch in this video write
those three thing three three things
down desire action purpose how do you
rank yourself with desire how do you
rank yourself with action and what is
your clear purpose definite purpose on
what you want out of your life that's my
message of the week to you and please be
sure to subscribe to this channel and
comment on the bottom thanks for
watching this video